[Música]
en primera plana
bienvenidos en primera plana un programa
de radio france internacional y de
france 24 esta semana casi por
obligación tenemos que poner el foco en
ucrania con la ofensiva de vladimir
putin y las repercusiones que pueda
tener nos acompañan para analizar todo
lo que está sucediendo en este estudio
fernando avakian especialista del
espacio postsoviético y ex consultor
ante la unesco bienvenido fernando
buenos días carlos vélez arrunátegui
periodista independiente bienvenida a
delia en dúplex con nosotros eleonora
tafur o especialista en rusia del
instituto de estudios políticos
internacionales de milán bienvenida
señora tafur o
muchas gracias
el planeta con los ojos puestos en la
ofensiva que de vladimir putin sobre
ucrania hoy nuestro asunto en primera
plana
lo que el mundo temió durante semanas se
ha materializado rusia atacado ucrania
con explosiones y uso de artillería en
varios puntos del país sucede después de
que putin reconociese las provincias
separatistas de la región fronteriza del
donbass ahora el presidente ruso ha
cruzado un punto de no retorno con
consecuencias imprevisibles según el
líder ruso se trata de una operación
militar que busca desmilitarizar pero no
ocupar el país aunque lo cierto es que
toma color de una invasión a gran escala
con todas las condenas de la comunidad
internacional hoy en primera plana vamos
a intentar analizar los elementos que
rodean esta ofensiva rusa para darles a
ustedes las claves para interpretar la
última hora que les vayan contando
nuestros compañeros de informativos
antes repasemos algunas portadas el
comercio de perú rusia ataca ucrania el
diario destaca la condena global los
ángeles times' ucrania bajo ataque
señala el diario que la invasión también
se juega en el ciberespacio 'new york
post' guerra en europa sorprende y ver
un titular así tan tan potente guerra de
nuevo en un suelo europeo
aquí en francia lo impensable empecemos
por este último titular fernando lo
impensable muchos temían la ofensiva
pero no la magnitud de este ataque es
decir
todo el mundo podía imaginar que podría
haber una ofensiva sobre el donbass pero
no sobre tantos puntos del mapa
ucraniano que es lo que pretende putting
hazte la pregunta del millón
ciertamente carlos decía churchill que
la política es el arte de
intentar predecir lo que va a ocurrir y
luego explicar por qué no ocurre por qué
y lo cierto es que pocos observadores se
esperaban a una guerra sobre todos los
frentes una guerra abierta y que no
solamente ocurriera en la región del
donbass en la cual las fuerzas rusas ya
estaban presentes si bien de modo un
poco oculto en una guerra híbrida
haciéndose pasar por pro rusos junto a
los separatistas la cuestión es que se
me ocurren dos interpretaciones una de
ellas es que justamente todo esto
estuviera bien planeado con un timing
perfecto
comenzando con las tropas rusas
estacionadas alrededor de ucrania
justamente cuando se termina la
construcción del gasoducto nord stream 2
y pasando a la acción luego de haber e
intentado mostrar algún tipo de
interés por la vía diplomática por otro
lado otra interpretación puede llegar a
ser que fue una serie de blas tras otro
es decir una serie como de intentar
asustar al occidente y el tono fue
aumentando la apuesta fueron creciendo y
llegó un punto en el cual ni occidente
ni rusia podrían echarse para atrás sin
perder digamos la imagen sin sin perder
un coste reputacional y así putin
terminó entrando a ucrania con todas sus
fuerzas del día lo que la diplomacia
intentado evitar durante tantas semanas
finalmente se ha producido quizá como
decía fernando estaba tan planificado
que quizá los juegos con la diplomacia
en la cabeza de putin estaban claros que
no iban a llegar muy lejos pero la
pregunta es hasta dónde puede llegar
putin o cuáles son sus objetivos finales
con toda esta ofensiva es una muy buena
pregunta yo creo que las tratativas
diplomáticas fue especialmente para
seguir un protocolo y quizás hasta de
forma táctica para permitir que las
fuerzas lleguen a las posiciones que
tenían que llegar y estén preparadas
para este ataque tan masivo y de alguna
forma así sorpresivo hasta dónde puede
llegar no se sabe por qué los límites en
este momento se han ido borrando los
últimos años lo que era intolerable hace
diez años ahora resulta más tolerable
hay que recordar que en 2014 cuando
invadió anexo crimea hubo sanciones y
existieron sanciones pero quizás no
suficientemente fuertes como para
desanimarnos desanimarlo a que continúe
este
estrategia militar y política de
expandir su territorio vamos que va a
preguntarle a nuestra especialista en
rusia en el instituto de estudios
políticos internacionales eleonara tafur
o eleonora cuáles son los intereses de
putin en ucrania
los intereses de putina han sido claros
desde el principio su interés principal
fue aquel de
separar la
digamos la avanzada así como la percibe
y de la otan en europa oriental sobre
todo con la ucrania y georgia es solo lo
puso muy claro en diciembre cuando
envió un listado de peticiones a otan y
eeuu
además hay desde luego muchas otras
razones porque es un fenómeno muy
complejo entonces hay muchas causas útil
siente que tiene que dejar un legado yo
creo a los rusos una tercera desde luego
o causa muy importante un intenta tivo
que rusia hizo de integrar desde el
punto de vista económico y político los
estados de la de la ex unión soviética
que digamos no tuvo éxito porque algunos
de estos estados en
karina sobre todo no quisieron
integrarse con rusia y decidieron por el
contrario intentar integrarse más con
unión europea y yo tan entonces esto
rompió un poco los los proyectos de la
denuncia sobre todo en a la unión
eurasiática
claro muchas preguntas nos deja todo
esto sobre la mesa entre ellas no sé qué
opinan del día a fernando se puede
convertir esta guerra en una guerra
larga que se dilate en el tiempo de baja
intensidad o será rápida por dónde
pueden ir los los planes de putin
fernando en alguna medida depende me
parece a mí de justamente de los
objetivos que estaban enumerando
eleonora es decir si lo que putin quiere
es la sumisión rápida de ucrania
obviamente le va a convenir simplemente
intervenir en kiev para intentar generar
un cambio de gobierno para imponer un
cambio de gobierno de modo tal que se
vuelva a una situación es que poner una
marioneta dependiente del boss se me
ocurre a mí que como como mínimo a putin
le hubiese le hubiese gustado tener una
especie de en un proceso de finlandés
acción de ucrania es decir que antes de
comenzar haría redujeran y simplemente
se transforme en un estado tapón un
estado simplemente
soberano pero que por otro lado no es
parte de la otan
completamente parte de la unión
euroasiática que nombraba eleonora y
como máximo que se transforme en algo
como bielorrusia que de facto está
prácticamente integrada a rusia
la cuestión es rusia tiene los medios
para mantener una guerra a largo plazo y
la cuestión es que es bastante costoso y
bastante riesgoso porque putin el
kremlin no tiene las capacidades para
controlar para controlar el territorio y
la población de ucrania digamos no ruso
zona y no ruso fila y del otro lado de
la respuesta que puede dar la otan bueno
ucraniano es miembro de la otan y no
está cubierta por la cláusula de
mutua defensa de la otan lo que se puede
quizá se podría hacer es suministro de
armas a que sea y el punto complicado no
totalmente es el pero también es
suministro de armas pero si no hay
suficientes
militares como para hacer uso de ellas
es muy complicado porque en ese momento
tanto la unión europea como norteamérica
con joe biden dicen que no van a
intervenir con con fuerzas militares
eso está clarísimo pero al mismo momento
se ha escuchado al presidente ucranio
decir que lo están sí diciendo que lo
están dejando solo por más que haya
ayuda humanitaria ayuda económica mismo
envío de armas es decir en algún momento
todo este tipo de ayudas ayudan pero no
son suficientes para que pueda hacer
frente a esta invasión rusa porque las
sanciones impuestas en las últimas horas
tanto por estados unidos como por la
unión europea parece que no se podemos
decir pueden tener algún tipo de
carácter disuasorio llegados a este
punto formando es que simplemente hay
ahí hay una doble temporalidad con
relación a las medidas que se están
implementando por un lado obviamente las
medidas militares son por esencia
más espectaculares y más inmediatas las
medidas las sanciones financieras y
económicas como por ejemplo aislar a
rusia en el plano financiero
internacional tienen efectos más a largo
plazo que se van a ver quizás de hará
seis meses un año etcétera entonces es
muy difícil hoy por hoy de saber cuáles
van a ser los efectos digamos disuasorio
estamos viendo que en este momento no
están disuadiendo putin voy a
preguntarle perdona voy a preguntarle a
leonora de cómo se vive esta crisis
dentro de rusia cuál es la percepción
que se tiene en rusia de la actuación de
putin de toda esta crisis y en general
de la política exterior del kremlin
eleonora
pues este es un tema que está causando
mucha mucha tristeza entre entre los
ciudadanos
en este momento rehusar una guerra
también de sondeos porque el kremlin
sabe perfectamente que en tumbas y una
una guerra contra ucrania no es la
anexión de crimea en 2014 que por lo
contrario él causó un aumento de la
popularidad del presidente esta
situación es muy distinta es una
situación violenta es un ataque que ha
causado están causando muchas víctimas
en el centro independiente levada por
ejemplo
dijo que solamente
alrededor del 40 por ciento de los rusos
aprobaban la regla digamos la
independencia de las dos repúblicas
separatistas en dos más mientras que
poco tiempo después salió otros sondeos
del centro opción que es un centro mucho
más
digamos
al kremlin que decía que este porcentaje
era el 70 por ciento y esto solo es para
lo que lo que concierne la independencia
de las dos repúblicas y luego miramos a
los sondeos sobre ucrania en general
vemos que la mayoría de los rusos no
tiene sentimientos negativos en contra
del de su cráneo sobre todo los jóvenes
y esto tiene que ver mucho con los
enlaces
históricos familiares políticos y
económicos que los dos países han tenido
a lo largo a lo largo de los años
claro es tan difícil saber y además creo
que van cientos de detenidos ya en rusia
por manifestarse contra contra esta
ofensiva lo que son datos muy
complicados de obtener por cómo es por
cómo rusia fernando una pequeña presión
como ya
causa claro la cuestión es de qué forma
se puede crear una imagen del otro al
cual se puede atacar teniendo en cuenta
que ucranianos y rusos siempre han
tenido una historia tan tan tan cercana
entonces no es lo mismo
es muy difícil crear la imagen del
enemigo que siempre ha sido nuestro
hermano vamos a hacer una breve pausa en
este punto y enseguida volvemos
analizando todo lo que está sucediendo
ucrania quien en primera plana
en la cee del cono sur a norte américa
de los andes a centroamérica una cita
semanal con los temas más importantes de
los países del continente americano
presentada por los corresponsales de
france 24
enlace en france 24 y france 24 puntocom
versalles el monte saint michel el
louvre son algunos de los monumentos
franceses más conocidos pero francia es
mucho más arte gastronomía arquitectura
paisajes descubra con france24 un
patrimonio vivo del aprendiz al experto
artesano del productor de quesos al chef
reconocido con su pasión mantienen el
patrimonio cultural de francia
esto es francia en france 24 y france24
puntocom
[Música]
france24 el arte en todas sus formas
liberté égalité actual y t
seguimos en primera plana esta semana
hablando de la ofensiva de putin sobre
ucrania lo hacemos con el especialista
del espacio postsoviético fernando
avakian de al jarreau unatec y
periodista independiente y en dúplex
también con nosotros eleonora tafur o
especialista en rusia del instituto de
estudios políticos internacionales de
milán y somos conscientes quizás no lo
sé en estos primeros momentos porque es
muy reciente este esta ofensiva de que
esta guerra se está celebrando en suelo
europeo en muchos analistas que hablan
de que quizá estemos hablando del peor
conflicto desde la segunda guerra
mundial delia yo creo que si hay una
conciencia general de que es un
conflicto que se está llevando en europa
también estamos viendo manifestaciones
en las embajadas rusas de muchas
capitales europeas y la cercanía afecta
de una forma muy directa también se
tiene conciencia de que puede haber un
flujo de
exiliados enorme edad también es muy
curioso ver el caso de polonia que en
este momento abierto totalmente su
fronteras y está listo para recibir este
gran flujo de
exiliados que van a venir eventualmente
de ucrania cosa que no pasó con otras
crisis pasadas no parece ser que europa
así que está ahora lista para acoger una
gran ola de refugiados que lleguen de
ucrania por lo que parece no hay que
tener en cuenta que también parte de los
del territorio ucraniano en algún
momento fue parte de polonia es decir
está la cercanía pero también se sienten
como hermanos
fernando sí pero bueno justamente para
retomar lo que lo que está diciendo unos
minutos atrás la cuestión es una vez más
esta creación de la alteridad radical es
decir el refugiado que viene de tal o
cual país no se parece tanto a mí
mientras que el refugiado ucraniano
me hace pensar un poco en mí en mi
familia lo cual obviamente injusto del
punto de vista ético pero ciertamente
genera una ola posiblemente de mayor
solidaridad en europa
una táctica política sobre todo de la
parte de polonia que tenía ciertas
fricciones graves con la unión europea
ahora a decir bueno estamos listos a
aceptar este gran flujo y esos van a ser
los bienvenidos lo cierto es que nos
hemos encontrado con una situación que
nadie ningún analista ha llegado llegó a
prever no sé si les parece que putin
jugando no con la diplomacia lo que sí
que está es marcando los tiempos de toda
esta crisis
fernando si partimos digamos en la
hipótesis de que realmente había
planeado todo esto verdaderamente si
está marcando los tiempos de esta crisis
si partimos del y post de la hipótesis
de que lo que ocurre fue que se le fue
de las manos y que escaló el conflicto
mucho más allá de lo que querría
simplemente está corriendo detrás de sus
propias acciones la cuestión es que
lamentablemente nunca lo vamos a saber
porque es verdaderamente el régimen es
opaco y es muy difícil hacer algún tipo
de análisis más certero
perdón pero en todo caso se le ve a
putin en todas las intervenciones que ha
tenido una seguridad y un aplomo que da
a pensar que era que estaba muy bien
calculado antes de hacerlo
también haber traído más de
175.000 militares era un movimiento
enorme para hacer sólo un grupo
maniobras militares me inclino a pensar
sobre todo la primera de las opciones
que era algo que ya estaba planeado
desde hace mucho tiempo vamos a seguir
hablando está haciendo ciertas
comparativas para poner esta crisis en
su contexto eleonora el reconocimiento
de moscú de los territorios su cráneo
separatistas ha provocado comparaciones
con operaciones rusas pasadas destinadas
a contrarrestar la influencia occidental
y reforzar la profundidad estratégica en
el antiguo bloque soviético recordemos
la de 2008 en georgia
apoyando a los separatistas de osetia
del sur y abjasia o el apoyo a un
régimen pro ruso en la región disidente
de moldavia transnistria hay similitudes
con la situación actual es también
traído estos paralelismos hay un hilo
conductor en esta línea de actuación de
putin
desde luego en un primer análisis
la comparación con los otros conflictos
congelados como se les llama
fue la que la mayoría de los analistas
utilizaron porque el conflicto en
ucrania ya lleva 8 años es un conflicto
que como decía causó muchas víctimas
pero que podía hacer comparado a los
super conflictos congelados pero con la
decisión de atacar a todo el país
putin a digamos ha marcado una intención
mucho más amplia respecto a recorrer
respecto a lo que hizo en georgia en
moldavia entonces este parangón yo no sé
hasta qué punto puede puede valer
después de la discusión del crimen
muy conocedor del espacio pos-soviético
fernando sobre todo rusia se considera
con ese derecho a una esfera histórica
de influencia putin lo ha dicho en su
discurso del lunes pasado
y el discurso especialmente agresivo que
putin pronunció el 21 de febrero
básicamente explica la forma en la cual
putin el espacio postsoviético y en
particular ucrania ciertamente es la
versión
del cree ming de la
doctrina monroe es decir este continente
o este subcontinente me pertenece en
particular
ucrania es decir de una óptica
nacionalista rusa y ucrania es el
subproducto por así decirlo de la
creación del estado ruso todo esto
digamos internal interpretando la
historia de la unidad política de rus de
quiere en el siglo 19
entonces
siente en alguna medida tiene como una
visión un poco patrimonialista para con
los países vecinos y en particular con
ucrania una versión que incluso mezcla
tiempos de la unión soviética con
tiempos del antiguo imperio ruso no es
eso es lo interesante porque en alguna
medida el discurso del pasado lunes 21
de febrero
casi que podría hacer pensar más en la
época del sadismo que en la época
soviética porque justamente dice que fue
culpa de los grandes errores
geopolíticos llevado a cabo en la época
soviética que ucrania existe es decir
dice en un momento dice fue lenin creo
ucrania utiliza otras palabras pero fue
lenin quien cree ucrania al ceder ante
ciertas élites locales nacionalistas
pero en realidad ucrania era rusia pero
pues bien tiene una gran capacidad de la
rectora relectura histórica
así que me pregunto muchas veces si
estaríamos ante una crisis como la que
estamos viviendo
si nos fue
putin no estuviera ahí es decir con otra
personalidad esta crisis tiene mucho de
personalismo de lo que es la figura de
putin no entiendo cilia ships y por
supuesto es esta su firma pero también
hay otros líderes oligarcas y políticos
que tienen esa visión de la rusia
imperial de la rusia como imperio y que
dicen sienten que ucrania pertenece a
rusia y sobre todo ahora cuando tomaba
cierta distancia y se acercaba más a lo
que es occidente sobre todo a la unión
europea con una democracia real más con
más apertura lo han tomado como una
afrenta casi personal
la cuestión es que hay para así decir
los dos polos dos planes
civilizacionales que actúan como como
centros de gravedad uno es obviamente
moscú y el mundo ruso otro es europa y
la idea de la civilización occidental
etcétera ambos son constructos
históricos teóricos culturales pero en
términos políticos se articula de modo
tal que por ejemplo si tal o cual país
por ejemplo georgia hasta el 2008
armenia en 2018 y ucrania hasta el
episodio de euro maidán si intentan en
alguna medida
luchar contra las viejas oligarquías que
mantienen el país siempre bajo la órbita
de moscú
necesariamente se acercan a europa en
términos civilizacionales y en términos
institucionales y políticos lo cual es
el terror de putin y justamente el
último peón que queda en la zona es
ucrania sin contraer bielorrusia que de
facto ha sido casi que integrada
abrimos de otro factor más china que
pasa con china en todas porque asistimos
a la condena de toda la comunidad
internacional excepto de china y
hablamos se empieza a hablar de un nuevo
orden mundial a través de esa alianza
entre putin y xi jinping quizá la
capacidad rusa para aguantar sanciones
no fuera tanta si tuviera las espaldas
bien cubiertas por chinas no sabemos si
se hubiera atrevido a tanto putin sin
esa alianza previa con china es muy
posible en el
comunicado que el presidente
norteamericano joe biden cuando le
hicieron la pregunta directa que pasaba
con china dijo que no podía dar ningún
tipo de opinión china bueno el partido
chino ha dicho que ellos no van a
pronunciarse ya que no desean ponerle
más leña al fuego yo creo que
definitivamente debe haber
conversaciones entre rusia y china- lo
interesante es saber en qué posición
está rusia ante china y qué tipo de
negociaciones si es en un estado de
como se puede decir de russian tanto que
igual o si china está negociando en
posición fuerte
es la gran pregunta pero vamos a
preguntar también a eleonora porque
muchos ven en la alianza de putin con sí
sin pin la creación de un nuevo orden
mundial cuál es la visión que este nuevo
eje tiene sobre el futuro del mundo
produce desde hace muchos años desde más
después del 2014 cuando se empezaron a
poner sanciones contra rusia intenta
dibujar la relación con china como este
nuevo eje para
no a revolucionar la orden mundial sino
que reformarla para que rusia y china-
tuviesen más peso político
yo creo que china desde su punto de
vista
puede gozar de unos beneficios
de las tensiones entre rusia y occidente
pero no tiene ningún interés
a un conflicto o tan tan amplio no sé
hasta qué punto china estaría dispuesta
a sacrificar sus intereses económicos
para apoyar a rusia entonces hay que
mirar
digamos cómo va a evolucionar la
situación y sobre todo cómo china va a
actuar si va a intentar mediar entre
entre rusia y occidente o simplemente va
a decidir no apoyar y terminar esta esta
nueva guerra
claro como dicen ahora parece un apoyo
fundamental fernando el apoyo chino a
rusia pero calibrarlos lo complicado
hasta dónde puede llegar yo creo que la
palabra sería o la expresión sería más
bien que en china está entre comillas
para citando la situación en el sentido
de que está simplemente aprovechando la
iniciativa rusa siempre obviamente
estando detrás de rusia ya está
eligiendo un campo pero como decía
eleonora no se va a jugar tanto no va a
ir tan lejos recordemos que en enero de
este año rus rusia y china firmaron un
acuerdo gasífero para qué china le
complica
a rusia esto se puede interpretar como
el ruso intentando diversificar aún más
sus compradores de gas teniendo en
cuenta que el 80 por ciento del gas ruso
se vende a europa entonces ciertamente
hay algún tipo de
entente la cuestión es hasta dónde
puedes llegar a ir y china siempre ha
sido muy prudente en el plano
internacional y seguramente está
aprovechando en alguna medida el impulso
ruso nos quedamos sin tiempo para más
pero bueno preguntas que nos surgen son
tantas tantas incógnitas en esta en este
escenario tan incierto que se abre con
con la ofensiva de putin en ucrania el
celular seguiremos contando por supuesto
aquí en radio francia internacional y en
france 24 a todos ustedes muchísimas
gracias les esperamos la próxima semana
quien en primera plana gracias
[Música]
ah